supporting with you soon now i am yes
okay um what happened yesterday because
it looks as though penny mordant was a
shoe-in to go through and she didn't
i think there's there's a lot of support
for rishi in the parliamentary party and
that was recognized in his coming top of
the ballot i think it'll be um you know
there'll be a tough contest ahead both
richie and liz are strong candidates but
i believe that he is the our best chance
of winning in the general election and
he's got a plan to get a grip on
inflation grow the economy and reduce
our taxes was there any skullduggery
with votes being handed around
well certainly not that i was aware of
but um
this is a victoriously sophisticated
electorate so some of my colleagues no
doubt did
probably different mps voted tactically
but um
the rishi campaign was strongly
encouraging all all its supporters to
vote for rishi we weren't engaging in
these tactical voting games because
penny morton of course would have been
some say a more formidable
challenger than liz trust do you agree
both penny annelise have great great
qualities i mean we had some fantastic
candidates in the mp rounds
now it's down to the membership to pick
the person who's going to win us a
general election
um are you going to are you going to
tell your candidates who stop tearing
lumps out of each other
i absolutely want a positive contest um
and some of the testing's comments were
you know it's always difficult when
you've got um
people within the same party competing
against one another but um i know rishi
wants to make a positive case about what
he's going to do to get us through
what are going to be very difficult
economic times do you think he regrets
the comment that he made on the itv
debate about but which she regrets more
being a remainer or being um
i mean that that wasn't the greatest
moment in his campaign i i
you know i i probably regret that i'm
i'm i'm not sure that was the right
thing to do but
the important thing is who is is going
to be the person to get us through this
inflation crisis and i think rishi has
demonstrated he's got the track record
and he's got the plan
to do that but he wants to
certainly not decrease taxes for now um
how will that go down with the party
faithful
i heard they'll recognize that actually
if both the two candidates want to
reduce taxes
but
rishi is the one who recognizes that
because of the inflation crisis that we
face because of covert debt
we need a degree of caution he's
determined to get our taxes down but
only once inflation is beaten first but
if somebody's offering jam today it's
very difficult especially in a cost of
living crisis to think oh actually i
won't vote for that
our members i think recognize that
thatcherism is about sound money as well
as low taxes mrs thatcher
her prime focus when she first arrived
as prime minister was fixing the public
finances and getting inflation under
control and grappling with economic
problems before she started
cutting taxes in a big way
why is there such a disconnect between
mps
conservative mps and conservative
grassroots voters because it looks as
though you know he's obviously very
popular your candidate with mps he won
the ballot easily but when it comes to
tory grassroots voters who will decide
who is the next prime minister he's not
quite as popular why is that
well to be honest we don't know what the
membership think polling conservative
party members is a notoriously difficult
thing you know politicians always say
this and it's a bit like and somebody
said to me upholster said to me
yesterday that the day before it's a bit
like um actors saying they never read
reviews of course you take notice of the
polls
i think i very much hope members will be
impressed by
rishi's three-point plan to get us
through these difficult economic times
we need someone who's demonstrated
that he can
he can have a grip on the government
that he can deliver
you know the policies we need to win us
a general election i believe that he
will get our taxes down but he won't he
wants to do it in a responsible way yeah
the problem is um him being a judas
according to some with the prime
minister is not going to serve him well
prime minister having a poverty
yesterday from the dispatch box
well i i don't believe in that kind of
characterization at all i think that's
that's really unfair
um i it's
it's obviously been very damaging to the
conservative party as a whole the
circumstances that led to a resignation
of a prime minister these these events
are deeply traumatic but now we need a
fresh start we need to elect a new
legion and then
unite behind that new leader do you
think that when the prime minister
yesterday was
saying what he was saying about don't
always
take the advice of the treasury um he
was particularly indirectly referring to
your guy
you'll have to ask boris and his team
that but yeah
it is important for any minister in a
department to challenge the orthodoxy of
their civil servants i'm sure rishi was
was able to do that in his time and i'm
sure if he does become our prime
minister he will be taking forward those
ideas in the manifesto on which we're
all elected
and um he'd be prepared to challenge the
civil servants to make sure that um
they deliver on those promises that we
made to the electorate at the general
election what did you make of labour not
standing up for the prime minister
yesterday
i'm sorry i didn't quite catch that
labour not standing up for the prime
minister to applaud him uh on his last
prime minister's questions yesterday
what did you think of that
well i i think it would have been
courteous for for everyone to have taken
part in that applause because as
an outgoing prime minister that's a huge
occasion and i believe that
boris has delivered a huge amount for
this country not least
getting brexit done and also
guiding us through
the worst health emergency for a hundred
years with one of the most successful
vaccine programs
in the world so i think that deserved
recognition and applause theresa may
didn't
well
that's a matter for her i mean if if you
have questions about that that's
there to be directed at her churlish
well i as i say i think um an outgoing
prime minister deserves applause
particularly one who leaves the country
with important benefits as a result of
his premiership
what are you most anxious about over the
next six weeks
where should i start where should i
start
um
i think anything can happen in this
membership vote but i know that
rishi and his team are going to be
working incredibly hard
to
um convince the members on this and
he'll be bringing forward fresh ideas on
how we fix the economy in particular how
we get business investing
how we improve our skills training so we
invest in
making us a more productive economy
because that's ultimately the thing
that's going to raise living standards
and getting get us through this
inflation crisis and what are you most
looking forward to apart from obviously
hoping that your candidate wins on the
5th of september is it the debate of
fortnight today
i think i'm quite looking forward to
this being parliament's
last day sitting before the summer
recess so that um
there's a few of us who who get a little
something of a break but um i think
we'll see some
some great debates in the hustings i
hope they're well attended by the
membership
and
i believe that the membership will
recognize that in difficult times we
need someone with proven experience and
an economic plan to get us through
difficult times